hey it's Evan and I believe that it's
important to thank the people in your
life we've had a positive impact and and
take time out of your busy week to every
now and then just appreciate them and
say thank you you know I really I'm
really appreciative of all the help
you've given me and so today is the
first time that I'm going to be thinking
a company instead of an individual
person and the company I wanted to thank
is tell us tell us is a big telco here
in in Canada and I'm grateful to tell us
for a couple reasons the first is they
helped open up a whole new business for
me so before I met tell us my business
was selling advertising I had a popular
website people came to the site nice old
advertising against that and tell us
came to me and said hey Evan we'd like
to hire you to create some content for
our blog and you can write about you
know whatever you want 300 500 words and
something that helps entrepreneurs and
you can link back to your site I said
hey this is a great deal you don't have
to write a little bit of content I love
helping out entrepreneurs anyway and
they going to link back to my site and I
get paid to do it why not it's great and
that first post did so well and had you
know tens of thousands of views and it
started a maybe three year relationship
where i was adding content on a regular
basis for them and it helped open up a
new business for me which is partnering
with brands so now I do actually do a
lot of work helping brands who are
trying to reach entrepreneurs a lot of
the big brands don't have a solid
understanding of how to reach
entrepreneurs and get their message out
so I help them with that and tell us was
my first client that made you realize
hey this is an opportunity and since
then over the years I've worked with
Google and Dell and american express and
Microsoft and banks and huge companies
but tell us was the first one and they
they reached out to me and saw something
in me I guess and and it was a great you
know run while it lasted the other thing
that I helped me realize was that you
know a lot of big brands we don't like
brands we
like dealing with big companies a lot
you know the service isn't great where
we're getting ripped off a lot you don't
get a you know personal connection with
people and a lot of the brands who
approached me before they just didn't
get it a lot of big brands still don't
get it you know they they come to me see
Evan hate we're trying to launch this
new product and we want you to pitch it
to your audience once you see how great
it is on our launch day here's the day
and we'll pay you X amount of dollars
and they just don't get it right like
that's not the way to sell to
entrepreneurs when I make a video when I
create content when I'm sharing stuff is
because i like it i actually use it and
i can talk about it and i shared because
i want to share it because think it's
going to help entrepreneurs if i got on
and just started pitching everybody's
product I'd lose my audience really
really quickly and it's still how a lot
of brides think for some reason but tell
us help show me that they had you know
there are brands that actually care
about entrepreneurs Telus actually cares
about entrepreneurs and they let me
write whatever content I wanted
something I thought would be helpful and
valuable and they were trying to build
relationships with entrepreneurs and be
seen as a friend of entrepreneurs and
since then I found other brands who had
that same philosophy and we've worked
really really well together got some
great results together but tell us was
the first one and I'm just really super
appreciative of the fact that they gave
me that first opportunity and they they
showed me that some brands do care about
entrepreneurs and are willing to invest
in the relationship and and you know why
we should care about them as well and in
particular Tasha Caruso was was amazing
a great point of contact a big champion
of entrepreneurs and also really
entrepreneurial within a big company so
it was really fun and interesting to see
so that's what i want to thank today
thank you guys so much for that for the
opportunities and for those of you
watching i hope you take time out of
your day today to go thank somebody just
let them know that you appreciate them
let them know you know that they're
important to you that they made a
difference somehow it'll make you feel
good and they'll make them feel good to
the belief
those you watch another video thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath if somebody who's had
an impact on your your life I'd love to
hear the story in the comments and if
you want to see more videos like this
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon